I have never rooted for someone maybe to
be just an unbelievable jerk I just
needed something to be wrong with him
and there was nothing he's annoyingly
funny hilarious like did you bring
writers or something he was killing it
we were talking about music and we're
playing something and I said what song
are you talking about and he started
singing and I did not mean to but very
uh it was deep in guttural I was like
you shut up
shut up Chris we have it also like he
started to sound like a songbird
you can't have another thing just just
be quiet I don't tell people to shut up
but I was like you shut up I bet he
doesn't even have boogers
if he does have boogers they taste like
corn flakes
[Applause]